um i want to talk about
a really serious issue
which is that we now know we know that
there are people on the political right
willing to do violence merely over
political disagreements and
that's why i was particularly worried
when i saw a headline indicating
that the nevada governor a democrat
steve sisilak
was confronted and had his life
threatened at a restaurant over the
weekend and um this is i mean listen uh
part of the content here is the fact
that sizzolak is out at a restaurant
without security
and it's sad that he probably needs
security all the time
but it is what it is and i'm going to
play the video for you in a moment um
two men accosted and berated steve
sisilak and his wife kathy hurling
racist language and threats as they
followed him out of a restaurant into a
parking lot
this is really ugly video nevada
governor sizolak and his wife kathy were
involved in a harrowing encounter two
men screamed racist and violent threats
in a statement shared to twitter the
communications director explained it
happened sunday when he was walking
through a restaurant to have dinner the
governor was approached by a customer in
the establishment who has to take a
photo
uh it then became clear that the guy was
just uh kidding around about wanting to
take a photo and started berating him
and saying are you in here without
security
following him another guy started
yelling swearing of course there was
covet disinformation uh riddled uh
within the riddling the harassment about
hydroxychloroquine etc when they started
to leave
um
sizzilock's wife is asian and one of the
guys started
yelling china piece of s
we should string you up by lamp posts
etc
let's take a look at the video
this is uh this is pretty horrifying
stuff
you steve syslag right
it's amazing i can't tell you what a
piece of it you are sorry to hear that
new world order trader piece of bastard
so
new world order conspiracy number one in
here without security
yeah you pieces
i'm surprised you have the balls to be
out here in public huh
out here without a cop out here without
security now one of the other things is
many of you are probably saying i had no
idea sizzulak was the governor of nevada
like he's not even a controversial guy
he he's a completely just
basic
democratic governor he's not
particularly progressive or anything and
and so it's not even really about any
particular policy
you got balls on you boy i'm not moving
wait till we find all the money that
pulled his way through oh man yeah
hiding the hydroxyl oh you in trouble
money that flowed his way
for hiding the hydroxychloroquine
these are sick people guys you can't you
can't go hey you know what let's talk
about our political differences again to
use this sort of banal example it's not
hey you know what you want a 42
top tax rate i want a 20 flat tax
let's talk about the origins of our
disagreements now
this is not that this is you've hidden
the money for you you've you've received
money for hiding hydroxychloroquine you
can't talk sense of these people they're
beyond reach
yeah you better get the [ __ ] out of here
i didn't go somewhere else where's your
security at huh huh
don't touch me lady where's your
security at huh you want to sell us all
down the river
are you working for china piece of [ __ ]
working for china so third conspiracy
so we've got new world order
uh receiving money and slash for hiding
hydroxychloroquine working for china
we should string you up by land post
right now [ __ ] boy and there's the
death threat string you up by a lamp
post sort of an uh alluding alluding
quite frankly to a lynching you know
what they do to traders
huh where's your security at i heard
about you banging that little girl and
wrecking your car does she know about
that huh steve
mr [ __ ] lack
you craziness china working [ __ ]
[ __ ]
where's your security at [ __ ]
you lucky i'm a law-abiding citizen
woo
because your daughter's with you i'm
going to leave you alone now
respectful guy huh
your daughter's with you so now i'm
going to leave you alone
patriots
this is considered patriotic in some
parts of the country
[Laughter]
so a lot of people like that i mean
that's considered um that now these are
the same people who if someone just
shows up with a sign outside mitch
mcconnell's house they'd go whoa these
these are private people
and they're being bothered
and that's really bad the tone is bad
and you shouldn't be allowed no and
look at what is going these are truly
dangerous people and you know i i know
enough people both in media and in
politics to know that
they you know you're supposed to like
not you're not really supposed to admit
that you're scared by that
but i've spoken to people in media and
politics who go this happened to me and
i was scared by it i really was because
these people are crazy
particularly in states where
everybody's got guns you know or at
least a lot of people do
this is genuinely horrifying stuff and
um i know that some of you are going to
write to me and say that was actually a
right-wing podcaster the guy who did it
i don't even care i don't i don't know
the guy's name i don't whether he's a
podcast or not i'm not gonna i'm not
even gonna give any i'm not gonna
mention the fact that that guy might
have some kind of show or anything like
that this is really really disgusting
stuff it's dangerous stuff
and i fear and i mean listen it's not
it's a i fear it's happened before
that violence is done against people
uh you can go back to the 80s gabby
giffords etcetera there's so many of
these examples um and the these people
are dangerous we can't for a second be
allowed to think it's just rhetoric
they're just expressing differences of
opinion differences of opinion hiding
money uh taking money for hiding
hydroxychloroquine
you're working for china i mean come on
guys very very dangerous stuff and i
don't know
how we root that out i really don't that
that's not a person you can sit down
with and have a rational conversation
with so i'm open to ideas from you guys
how do we fix this stuff i don't know
one of our sponsors is blinkist who's
been supporting the david pakman show
longer than any other sponsor blinkist
is the app that lets you listen to or
read an entire non-fiction book in just
15 minutes blinkist is the way to absorb
those books you can't make time for
blinkist takes top non-fiction titles
pulls out the book's key takeaways and
insights and gives it to you in the form
of a text or audio explainer that you
can consume in 15 minutes with blinkist
now you actually do have time to learn
about all the things you've been wanting
to tackle on the blinkist app i just
listened to this is your mind on plants
by the great michael pollan
super interesting the history of
caffeine and so many other things
blinkist has you covered on podcasts too
blinkist takes long episodes of popular
podcasts and distills them into audio
you can listen to in 15 minutes with
blinkist you can become knowledgeable
about so many different things you can
have conversations with people about
more topics blinkist makes you more
well-rounded
try blinkist for free and get 25 off a
subscription go to blinkist.com
pacman the link is down below